[Music]
Jesus Christ this is an enormous bedroom
for one kid how many desks does he need
seller shadowing also I guess mom stop
playing the piano just in time for
Georgie to enter the cellar but takes no
notice of him whatsoever
of course her rampant negligence is
possibly the best parenting in the movie
oh yeah because bill has had a very busy
day of lying in bed and trying not to
vomit out of his nose anymore
there was no need for bill to tell
Georgie to hurry up therefore we get the
first of many unnecessary jump scares
from this movie kid is afraid to go down
in the cellar and the lights which
doesn't work cliche why in the hell do
they store the flashlights in a dark
basement and if Georgie knew this was
here why didn't he go for that in the
first place how the hell did Georgie not
see the second barricade if he clearly
saw the first one this whole movie can
be blamed on Georgie's inability to view
things in three dimensions do you want a
balloon too Georgie I'm not supposed to
take stuff from strangers Georgie knows
not to take stuff from strangers but was
not taught to never talk to clowns in
full makeup that live in storm sewers in
smell destroy tea there's peanuts cotton
candy hot dogs
I get that penny wise things kids are
stupid and rightfully so however zero
kids would find it appetizing to go eat
a fucking hot dog in the sewer why
didn't you just stick to the hole if you
want your boat you're gonna have to come
down here and get a tactic also
considering Georgie is so scared to walk
down a few stairs into the cellar why is
he even considering going down into a
sewer with a clown in it to retrieve a
paper boat what about the first scene
indicated that bill would even be upset
if Georgie lost it go ahead and take
office in four bills cars guards
performance here because this scene is a
perfect encapsulation of everything that
makes penny wines terrifying I mean look
I'm smile also having said that this is
really the only time penny wise is
allowed to be truly creepy everything
that comes after this is reliant on
effects or jump scares rather than this
disturbing dialect and his shadowy
presence so kudos for creating an
amazing character movie but also here's
a sin for showing leat too much of them
later there are two places you can be in
this world you can be out here like us
or you can be in there like them or you
could get a job that doesn't involve
brutally murdering sheep if that's not
your thing
even back when this was written in 1986
we knew there'd be a kids being bullied
by older kids Stephen King story line
nice frisbee flamer that's like
everything sister you got a free ride
this year cuz your little brother
Henry's bully Boehner was cock-block for
a full eight month due to Georgie's
disappearance the sense does that make
yeah man that was some excellent
bullying right there I can't wait to
learn more over the summer Beverly in
her backpack are looking extremely clean
after just having had water poured all
over her geez doesn't anyone actually
ride their bike home from school the
Barons it's the only place that that
that Georgie could van he's gone doe
look I know all the parents in this
movie or dickheads and that the Georgie
situation was hard on bills dad but the
Barons are pretty fuckin close right
could they not just drive out there and
check to make sure he's not right
[Music]
wouldn't have made more sense for Mike
to go in the store and hide out he's
literally right outside the fucking door
if this is it why is he just now
starting to terrorize Mike or really any
of the kids he ate Georgie is Pennywise
eight months ago and snacked on Betty
rips in' but decided to wait until
summer for the main course other than
seeing Henry and his gang be a bunch of
dicks there's zero context as to why
they were going to run over Mike and
Henry screaming stay the fuck out of my
town makes no sense if he didn't read
the book or see the original miniseries
and you know how he feel about that here
totally get that
Pennywise can take whatever form it
wants to that's established pretty early
on but now he can make things disappear
off paintings he's able to quit matter
in space this way why go through all the
trouble of fucking with these kids
before killing them he could just turn
their house into a sandwich and eat away
door opens slowly and creaks loudly
because horror movies got a horror
first you said the Barons and I are
saying the sewer I mean see it caught
sure is lucky for it that bill convinces
all these kids to go to the sewer where
all the killings take place like
shouldn't Pennywise be hanging around an
arcade or movie theater the really want
some kidney and this book of exposition
goes from sawmill workers to child
murder and just a few pages also luckily
been landed exactly on this section of
the book considering he randomly opened
it in the middle for some reason movie
does a great job here of creating
tension with something as simple as
random characters in the background
staring makes you wish the director had
relied more on ideas like this and less
on jump scares however great bit so I
listen the fact that the supposedly
intelligent character picks up this
foreign object leads me to believe that
Jeremy retailer is secretly auditioning
for role in the next Fantastic Four
reboot sure seems odd that Pennywise
picks this one group of kids that are
either already friends or about to
become friends I guess it's possible all
the kids in Derry or having these
encounters but some mention of that
would have been a nice addition to the
proceedings egg boy dude he just read a
story about Easter eggs so now he's
typecast as egg boy are you off to tits
you see that's a much better insulting
nickname also I know Henry's a
troublemaker and a bully and all that
but was he literally hanging out next to
the library in order to harass Ben as
soon as he came out how long has he been
waiting Jesus Jerry might have a bigger
problem with a countless number of
serial killers in the making resigning
here than it ever will was some demonic
alien clamp spell truly confused about
what Henri is capable of not to mention
he kept holding Ben after Patrick tried
to Michael Jackson in with the homemade
flamethrower night actually he might be
relieved that the only evidence that
links his son to the attempted murder
was lost
how in the hell the discount Adam driver
and his buddy not catch up to Ben I know
they pause briefly to discuss Henry's
knife but they were right behind it up
until now there's been only one path
whose sneaker is it it's pretty robust
oops look I understand writing your name
on your backpack or your gym uniform
like that but you're fing sneaker did
she do this with both of them also this
autographed shoe just happens to be the
first fucking item these kids come
across in the suit oh I got to meet you
before you died this is a nice gesture
and all to help Ben out but wasn't just
taking him to a doctor have been a bit
of crawl well how about that
you look just like Lois Lane look it's
not the movies fault because Stephen
King wrote these parts but I'm gonna
give us into this town for not having a
single redeemable adult character also I
guess this is the only instance of it
being lucky that the pharmacy is run by
a pedophile so that bill and his crew
can steal the stuff first I'll go
how did Bev time this so perfectly bill
just told her we were thinking am I
going to the board tomorrow but he
didn't tell her what time and she can't
have been waiting here since she just
pulled up in the middle of the pack if
this water shallow enough to touch all
of them should have died when they
jumped it I don't know it's possible to
make a horror movie about a demonic
clown one of the best coming-of-age
stories of the year but it happened
these shots of childhood summer
nostalgia gave me chills and deserve a
send-off and I promise that's the last
one people tired
disappeared six times the national
average and that's just grown-ups kids
are worse how is there a terrible
national average when Pennywise only
shows up every 27 years like an
unpunctual cicada
where was the loss I don't know
somewhere in town I guess then knows
everything about Derry yet neglects
basic geography I mean I know the well
house isn't there anymore but it was
surely on those old maps that bill was
just looking at look I know it can take
any form and the kids are scared of
different things but none of these other
monsters are anywhere close to being a
scariest Pennywise and apparently all
the kids are scared of the clown so why
not just stick with that well so dowdy
[Music]
wait why didn't Pennywise kill Eddie I
realized he's trying to build a fear in
the town but he's got this asshole
cornered in his backyard it should be
easy Jesus I bet the bathrooms in the
rundown leper house Eddie was just a
tour cleaner than this one door looks
like it needs a tetanus shot they have
seemed surprised to see an aggressive
hair clog when she was the one that
dumped all that hair directly into the
drain last night once again it had a kid
in his grasp and decided to be a bloody
dick instead of killing Beth I mean why
didn't Betty rips him get the same
consider
- yo wait it is a singular entity write
it more than almost anything but there
aren't multiples of it so how is he
posing as Georgie and Pennywise at the
same time well I guess that's that I
spent all this time planning this attack
but that clever little bastard countered
with the old run up the stairs move what
is it you'll see or maybe you won't
damnit this movie is way too good to be
busting out of protracted you better
come take a look at this cliche what
happened in here man I couldn't see it I
thought I might be crazy even after
they're in the bathroom Bev refuses to
tell them that a hair clog attacked her
then puke blood all over the walls if
they can all see the blood
then how did Beverly get cleaned up the
night before she was covered in the
blood and there's no way she would have
been able to use this bathroom wow this
is just the most adorable adolescents
banding together to clean up demonic
blood montage than I've ever seen and I
can't tell you how many of those just
popped into my head it's like him but
there is this why would Eddie mention
the clown here the only thing that
attacked him was the ghost leper outside
the house can only virgin see this stuff
is that why I'm not seeing this listen I
love fin wolfhard and he's hilarious in
this movie but why is this character
here the movie spent the entire first
hour painstakingly showing us the
interactions between it and every other
one of these kids but Richie apparently
even gets on the nerves of immortal
demons wait isn't that the home school
kids bike you know the kid we introduced
45 minutes ago and found him so
interesting that he's never been brought
up again we have to help them damn I
know this is a small town residential
street but there are obviously cars that
come through here these kids are dicks
to those drivers Henry cements his
status as biggest dumb ass in movie
history by literally letting this rock
thrown at a considerable distance hit
him right in the fucking head mom oh
it's definitely existed in the late 80s
the term was not coined until 1994 by
the Beastie Boys in their song mullet
hit Lethal Weapon - who is showing at
the dairy theatre on July 4th even
though it wasn't released nationwide
until July 7th of 1989 my grandfather
thinks his town is cursed he says that
all the bad things that happen in this
town are because of one thing an evil
thing but he has no problem sending his
grandson into this town on a regular
basis to deliver meat hi Richard what
are you afraid of clowns then why the
hasn't Pennywise the clown shown himself
to Richie this turns into a fairly scary
scene but I'm more distracted by the
fact that Bill's family got three
fucking pictures of One Flew
clearly between this Stanley's creepy
painting and the book Ben was looking at
in the library earlier
Pennywise is really ambition his trick
photography yeah but it's not
pitch-black in here even with the
projector light off you can clearly see
the light coming through the curtains on
the windows
Piazza if you say it's summer one more
time bill would be excellent at
cinemasins
[Applause]
it's not even like it had to try to
separate these guys I know they're kids
and all but they've all been shown to be
much smarter than they act as soon as
they get into the fucking house
Eddie's broken right arm looks
miraculously unbroken right after his
fall also once again it is content to
just scare the crap out of this kid then
run away instead of finishing the job
hey Ritchie just heard Eddie yelling for
them on the other side of the door but
immediately follows the demon here who
sounds nothing like I do mind you into
the strange room bill has a great sense
of dramatic timing and is able to open
the door precisely when Ritchie is being
attacked oh I've heard of you miss mash
after years and years of overprotective
mother ring that would make the mom from
Pink Floyd the wall anxious Sonia dishes
out some classic slut-shaming so we can
officially understand how awful of a
person she is we all know no one else is
going to do anything how the hell does
Bev know this exactly
they haven't even tried to approach the
police or a single adult to explain
what's going on yeah is anyone gonna pin
to that they called Eddie's mom about
his arm right and the last time Ben had
a knife wound they were all super
concerned but this time he's been
slashed open by a fucking demon and
they're cool with it
Georgie is dead take it back
protagonists fight amongst themselves
before the climax of the movie cliche
and
[Music]
damnit a conflicted between assigning a
sin for the sad music plays before the
inevitable reunion of the protagonist
cliche and celebrating the use of XT C's
dear God okay
once in for the first part and we'll
call the second part wash wait so it
just stopped editing for an entire month
I know Bev stabbed him in the head at
the well house but he didn't seem that
hurt I mean the thing only eats every 27
years but it's good with taking a whole
four weeks off
right your medication their placebos
Greta just happens to be present at the
drugstore to give Eddie some bitchiness
position to lead to the final act would
it Henry to kill everyone I thought it
needed the children to feed on before he
can hibernate and should me be preying
on Henry instead of getting Henry's
murder boner growing he's the same age
as Patrick and he ate that motherfucker
come the hell on why would Pennywise
wait until this fucking moment to abduct
Bev and the other times he's killed the
kids have been in the sewers but this
time he makes a house call haha
Pennywise seriously need to use the
front door
it was fucking padlocked okay I know
that it would totally be a general wave
group of kids would initially describe a
demon but couldn't they evolve into
something more descriptive like the
killer clown or mangina dentata naming
it it confuses everyone more than the
Knights who until recently Sydney I
understand that he doesn't want to keep
the Bulls pills around but that is a
perfectly good fanny pack he just threw
away that could actually come in handy
for carrying supplies on this mission so
penny wise chose to keep Beverley alive
just because he knows the losers Club is
coming to try and rescue her regardless
so why is she still breathing and yeah
yeah there's some comment later on about
Beverley not being scared so that's why
he couldn't kill her but that even if
that wasn't a bullshit throwaway excuse
they've talked about how fucking scared
they are this entire movie this is
hilarious and creepy and all that but -
penny wise need to put on this clown and
pony show for Beth he knows he can do
his glowy mouth trick to swallow her
soul or whatever so this silly dance is
purely for the audience which makes no
sense jeez there's always a secondary
human villain in a Stephen King story
isn't there this character might as well
be named ace Walter Big Jim Lloyd mother
Carmody
really say you just happened if it has
the ability to separate Stan from the
group why can't he do it to all of them
just so we can get another unnecessary
appearance from the picture lady and its
movies great but also it's at least 15
minutes longer than it needs to be is
the changing of the it appearance from
The Painted Lady to the clown really
that more terrifying this seems like a
massive waste of hit powers bill knows
this is not Georgie and grabs the gun to
kill it but he just had that speech
about how they need to stick together he
couldn't say one thing to the group
before he ran the fuck off considering
everything that's happened up to this
point beverly floating in the air should
be something that feels pretty ordinary
to these kids this works even though it
is solely dependent on fear for food he
goes for the heartstrings in bills case
for some reason she fast
Georgie Popov she actually in this case
you call boats her mr. grammar nazi' of
course this final confrontation between
children and an immortal hell spawns
gonna come down to good old-fashioned
punching and kicking kids are floating
down does this mean Ben and his magical
lips are about to get a workout so we're
none of them charged with any crimes
related to the murder of Henry Bowers I
know the town's used to kids going
missing it all but they would have found
his car outside the house then had all
the missing kids in it right hi
Jesus I know this is an emotional
farewell but the end of this movie makes
The Return of the King look like a
one-act play
Hey
sewer rat meat tastes like pumpkin pat
but I never know cuz I wouldn't need to
fill him up
ever since cinemasins began the most
requested thing has been TV since and
now it's a reality click the link in the
description below to check it out
and now the audio outtakes
[Music]
[Applause]
thousand hi I'm Garrett pumpkins I'm not
afraid of you you will be you will be
well if you're crazy and we're all crazy
we all go a little mad sometimes the
high ground yet sir cyst about 167 times
and I can't get funnier every single
time I sit
[Music]
son you got a penny on your head